le prédateur était présent il
m'attendait il m'avait demandé une heure
avant d'aller acheter des préservatifs
il voulait avoir des rapports avec cet
enfant
bonjour Alors moi je suis une maman de
trois enfants et femme de ménage dans la
vie de tous les jours à côté je suis
également la co-fondatrice du collectif
la teamour et auteur du livre les
prédateurs sont dans la poche de vos
enfants aux éditions Télémaque c'est un
mouvement citoyen qui est né à La
Réunion à l'initiative de Steven Moore
dont le but est de compromettre des
prédateurs sexuels et de les remettre à
la justice en créant des profils
d'enfants virtuel sur le net on se fait
passer pour des mineurs on crée un
profil d'enfant on utilise nos photos
avec lesquelles on rajoute un filtre
rajeunissant pour ne pas être accusé
d'un teinte au droit à l'image et
d'usurpation d'identité on laisse le
prédateur entrer en contact avec nous
pour ne pas être accusé d'incitation de
provocation au délits et enfin surtout
on ne diffuse pas l'identité de l'auteur
des faits ainsi que les échanges
récoltés sur internet pour ne pas être
accusé d'attente à la vie privée donc ce
sont des points très importants à
respecter tout a commencé en avril 2019
lorsque j'ai visionné plusieurs
reportages donc celui de Karl Zeroes le
fichier de la honte d'enfants la fin du
des reportages qui est mon profondément
bouleversé et à force j'ai voulu agir à
mon humble niveau et une amie virtuelle
m'a fait connaître la page Facebook que
tenez Steven Moore qui lui avait déjà
commencé à entreprendre ses activités
j'ai voulu le rejoindre et faire la même
chose et lorsque j'ai mis mon premier
enfant virtuel en ligne j'ai été alpagué
en l'espace de quelques minutes un
espace de quelques heures par des
dizaines d'hommes et j'ai pu voir
l'ampleur du phénomène et de là nous
avons décidé de créer un mouvement et
qu'il fallait des milliers sur la toile
à faire ça le collectif est composé de
50 personnes à 80% d'anciennes victimes
qui ont été touchées de près ou de loin
par la pédocrinalité et qui se sont
donnés pour mission de protéger les
enfants alors c'est l'activité au sein
de la teamour a réveillé en moi des
mauvais souvenirs qui étaient qui
étaient enfouis lorsqu'on a un enfant
sur le net on est contacté par des
adultes des hommes principalement qui
vont faire des propositions sexuelles on
déplace dans deux catégories donc il va
y avoir les pervers ceux qui vont parler
de sexualité tout de suite qui va
envoyer des photos de son élections qui
vont et les faux anges cardiaques qui
vont être dans la manipulation de
l'enfance ça va prendre des semaines
voire des mois mais c'est toujours le
même procédé dans le sens où ils veulent
des photos nues de l'enfant qui veulent
donner des rendez-vous dans le plus
avoir des rapports sexuels il faut
comprendre qu'on ne peut pas envoyer de
photos pour pas créer d'incitation on
est sans arrêt en train de repousser le
prédateur en lui rappelant
systématiquement notre âge mineure il
faut à la fois le repousser mais en même
temps continuer à parler avec lui pour
pas qu'il se lasse parce que sinon il va
parler à de véritables enfants nous
avons fait plusieurs rendez-vous qui ont
été imposés par le prédateur donc ce
n'est pas l'inverse sinon on est encore
une fois accusé de provocation au délit
en 2019 je me suis déguisé en petite
fille et je suis allée au rendez-vous le
prédateur était présent il m'attendait
et j'ai voulu démontrer que ça ne
s'arrête pas virtuel que on est bien
dans le réel ils sont prêts à se
déplacer il m'avait demandé une heure
avant d'aller acheter des préservatifs
il voulait avoir des rapports avec cet
enfant alors quand on va au rendez-vous
il faut comprendre que c'est lorsque la
justice c'est trop longue ou que nos
signalements sont ignorés
parce que dans l'absolu on envoie un
signalement en amont pour prévenir les
agissements de tel ou telle personne et
nous faisons ce que nous appelons une
arrestation citoyenne donc article 73
lorsqu'on va au rendez-vous et que
l'individu se présente on appelle les
forces de l'ordre pour qu'ils viennent
d'arrêter et constater qui s'est déplacé
après des échanges numériques lors des
rendez-vous on leur fait comprendre
qu'ils ont été piégés dans le sens où il
pensait converser avec un mineur leur
fait comprendre que nous sommes des
adultes que et que ils sont sur le coup
de la loi et qui sont dénoncés aux
autorités c'est inquiétant dans le sens
voilà les prédateurs sexuels qui nous
contactent sont de plus en plus jeunes
ils ont entre 20 et 25 ans ils sont
accro à la pédopornographie donne des
rendez-vous à des enfants qui ont entre
12-13 ans donc c'est inquiétant dans le
sens où qu'est-ce qui va advenir de ces
personnes là dans 10 ou 15 ans si on les
prend pas on cherche tout de suite ça va
être les mêmes méthodes soit ils vont
être pervers ils vont parler de
sexualité tout de suite soit ils vont
manipuler l'enfant ou alors pire ils
vont se faire passer eux-mêmes pour des
mineurs beaucoup se font passer pour des
enfants ils vont jouer en ligne sur des
jeux qui sont adaptés à des mineurs pour
se faire passer pour des enfants et
pouvoir avoir un contact avec eux
réseaux sociaux jeux vidéo je en ligne
du moment qui a moyen de chat il y a un
prédateur les plateformes sont obligés
de collaborer avec la police donc savoir
que quand on a une enquête est ouverte
c'est qu'un officier gendarmerie ou de
police demande une adresse IP à la
plateforme des fois ça va prendre des
semaines entre 6 et 8 semaines donc
c'est très long mais
les plateformes doivent prendre leur
responsabilité maintenant elle est
arrivée que des individus ont été
condamnés à du sursis que 18 mois plus
tard ils ont recommencé ils sont
retombés sur nous on les a re-signalés à
nouveau donc vu qu'ils avaient du sursis
ils ont pris du ferme cette fois-ci les
peines étaient plus fermes dès le départ
il y aurait moins de récidive et moins
d'activités pédocrinelle sur Internet au
départ les chefs de la police donc
Monsieur béro et Madame Béchu
on dit littéralement dans la presse que
nous étions hors-la-loi que nos éléments
n'étaient pas recevables au de la
justice et on a démontré que notre
activité respectée un cadre légal et
nous avons comme un permis des dizaines
de condamnations donc du ferme et du
sursis donc nous avons persévéré et
démontré que ce que nous faisons était
d'utilité publique était nécessaire et
que sans notre activité ces individus
serait passé sous les radars de la
justice alors aujourd'hui nos rapports
avec les magistrats et les autorités se
passent très très bien ils sont forts
cordiaux dès qu'on envoie un signalement
il est pris en charge une enquête est
ouverte et l'individu est arrêté alors
lorsqu'on a suffisamment d'éléments pour
signaler l'individu donc on répertorie
tous les délits donc ça va être la
proposition sexuelle la demande de
photos nul envoie de photos
pornographiques on monte un dossier avec
tous les éléments récoltés sur
l'identité d'individu son lieu de vie
son métier etc et nous envoyons un
signalement au procureur dont dépend
l'auteur des faits savoir quand on
décembre 2019 nous avons passer un
mouvement dans lequel nous avons permis
la création de plusieurs collectifs et
associations qui utilisent la même
méthode tous les résultats entre leur
groupe ainsi que le nôtre nous sommes à
plus de 200 arrestations à travers le
monde pour notre part nous avons permis
la condamnation de 37 individus qu'il
faut comprendre aussi c'est que nous
n'avons pas les suites puisque nous ne
sommes pas la victime réelle la victime
n'existe pas donc nous ne sommes pas
tenus de savoir les suites de l'enquête
donc c'est au bon vouloir du magistrat
ou des forces de l'ordre ou alors on
apprend à l'issue du dossier lorsque
l'affaire a été médiatisée aujourd'hui
on demande un statut un cadre légal
depuis quelques années un cadre légal
qui nous a été promis par Emmanuel
Macron en 2019 on est en 2023 à ce jour
rien n'a été fait pour que notre
collaboration et notre travail avec les
forces de l'ordre soit officielles même
si elle fonctionne très bien dans
l'ombre on voudrait avoir un statut on
réclame aussi le durcissement des peines
déjà que les peines en vigueur soit
appliquées mais qu'elles soient durcie
une meilleure prise en charge victime
une meilleure écoute de la parole de
l'enfant la reconnaissance de utiliser
traumatique et en militent pour que le
gouvernement met plus de moyens parce
que on démontre que avec zéro euro avec
aucun moyen et de la volonté on arrive à
faire bouger les lignes alors j'ai voulu
écrire ce livre qui est à l'origine est
un journal de bord dans le sens où
j'écrivais les choses pour moi je
racontais ce que je veux tous les jours
à travers le collectif et puis au bout
d'une cinquantaine de pages je me suis
dit je vais je vais en faire un livre il
faut que tout le monde sache à la fois
de la prévention c'est à la fois un
guide pour détailler les quatre
juridiques de ce qu'on fait et c'est une
chose d'information sur des affaires
pédocriminelles et des réseaux
pédocrinels qui qui ont eu lieu donc
voilà j'ai vraiment voulu faire j'ai
voulu exprimer à travers cet ouvrage
vous le mal qu'on peut voir ce à quoi
les enfants sont confrontés et faire de
la prévention auprès des parents ce
livre est indispensable ce livre est
important dans pour prendre conscience
du fléau pédocrinel qui existe sur les
réseaux et de l'inactivité de notre
gouvernement à vouloir protéger nos
enfants alors en tant que maman et citoy
je n'avais pas les outils pour le
prévenir parce que je ne savais pas
j'étais ignorante je ne savais pas que
ce fléau était à ce point grandissant et
du coup grâce à la teamour en faisant
cette activité j'ai pu faire de la
prévention auprès de mes enfants et je
trouve que mon nez en manque d'outils on
est en manque de ressources et de savoir
et qu'il est indispensable de pouvoir
instaurer un dialogue avec son enfant de
le prévenir de lui donner les codes
d'Internet comme quand on lui apprend à
faire du vélo on lui a inculque le col
de la route internet c'est pareil il
faut pas parler n'importe qui faut pas
donner son identité des informations
personnelles et les très important que
les enfants doivent savoir comment se
comporter sur Internet